the fastest way to sleep with a woman is
not try to sleep with her especially
beautiful women her whole life men are
either cat calling her or men are
aggressively trying to sleep with her
whole life she's like dodging penis you
know her whole life the second she gets
boobs so if you sit there and treat her
like she's not this [__] alien cuz
she's so beautiful bro she's going to be
like drop her hand she's be like wait a
second he's not trying to drop B stick
her ass you know what I'm saying you
know did not go in that direction but no
because now what you're doing is like
girls are like oh this guy's being a
nice he just wants to get in my pants I
feel like that's a dangerous message to
share no that's not what I'm saying what
was the Boom Part then the point I'm
trying to make is so many guys are very
obviously trying to sleep with the girl
if you can just treat her like a normal
person not put her on a pedestal and
talk to her just like I'm talking to you
and get to know that person women want
connection